>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> Shana Kimball: On January 6th the
New York Public Library gave a big
gift to the world, we enhanced
access to 187,000 items
in our digital collections
that we had determined were
in the public domain,
providing high res downloads
of the very best quality available
for everyone to download and enjoy,
including so many treasures from our
collections, including photographs
from Berenice Abbott documenting,
the changing New York City
landscape, cyanotypes of algae
from Anna Atkins, this is the
first photographic work known
to be published by a woman.
Photographs from the Farm
Security Administration.
Prints from the Works
Progress Administration.
Maps, so many maps, over 20,000.
This is a Bromley map from the
1920s showing the landscape
of where our workplace is,
the New York Public Library.
Sixteenth Century Japanese scrolls
depicting the Tale of Genji.
And stereographic images,
this one showing a view
from the Capitol Building
pointing northeast.
So a lot of great stuff.
But this offering, it wasn't easy to
do, it posed some challenges for us.
First of all, let's just be honest,
187,000 is not a sexy
number, it's not a million.
We also weren't the first to
do this, so many of our peers
in the worlds of like libraries
and museums had been there before,
and we knew we were not kind
of doing something brand-new.
And also this is a heterogeneous
collection of materials
and copyright designations
and the public domain section
was just one sort of aspect
of that broader collection, so
we knew that we needed to figure
out a way to bring this
offering into sharper focus.
We needed a set of strategies
to really launch this properly.
And we developed these strategies
really coming from the work
that we do in NYPL Labs,
which is the team that sort
of headed up the release.
We're responsible for digitizing the
Library's collections and we believe
that digitizing our
collections and providing access
to them is a really important
first step, but not the last step.
We know that the magic really
happens when those materials get
into the hands of users and they
can use them to create new things.
Before I get into this story more
fully let me introduce our speakers.
Myself, I'm Shana Kimball.
I'm the Manager of Public
Programs and Outreach at NYPL Labs,
and with Josh co-led this project
to release our public domain items.
Okay, and this is Greg Cram,
Associate Director of Copyright
and Information Policy at the New
York Public Library, and Josh Hadro,
the Deputy Director of
Labs and, like I said,
my co-conspirator in this project.
I'm going to hand it
over to Josh now.
>> Josh Hadro: Okay, yes, I'm
Josh, Deputy Director, NYPL Labs.
The three of us are the ones up
here doing the song and dance
and telling you about the
PD release that we did,
but it is obviously the work of
dozens of current colleagues.
But some of the ways you think about
it is this is in some ways the work
of all of the people who have
worked at NYPL, right, gathering,
preserving and making available all
those assets since 1895 up to today.
So, I don't know, I
haven't counted them,
but hundred if not
thousands of people.
So to give you kind of an overview
of the program that Shana and I
and Greg were working on, we broke
it out into four different sections.
The first covering kind of the
raw interface updates and the way
that we made the images available
through our digital
collections platform.
Also, some of the API updates and
the repository release that we did
to make the data available, but also
some of the rights work that Greg
and his team worked on to
make it really easy to know
which materials were
available for use and reuse.
And then kind of the last piece
that really tied it all together,
that made it appealing, I
called it the honey pot, right?
Setting it out and making
it desirable for people
to use the materials
and incorporate them
and put them back into the culture.
So to start this is our
digital collections platform.
I'm very proud of it.
We're all very proud of it.
I actually spoke at DPLA Fest
2015 to a similar group of you all
about our then newly revised
digital collections platform,
and we had undertaken kind of a
wholesale rewrite of the interface
and how we made the images available
and the metadata available.
For the January release we were able
to update the interface once more
and this time really put a lot of
energy on the specific engagement
around the public domain materials.
So figuring out ways to surface
just the assets that are available
in high res and get people
to click on the download link
so that they could use them.
There's a little kind of
interaction video here
that shows you the search filtering
that we put in front and center
on all the different pages.
So the search filter for the
public domain materials is front
and center, highlighted green
so that people wouldn't miss it.
And then once you get to the
asset page we really called
out all the derivative types that
we had available and put those front
and center, along with
the right statements
that makes it really obvious which
materials are able to be downloaded
without any kind of restriction.
So beyond that we also
made some improvements
to the underlying infrastructure.
So by volume that interface
is the mechanism
by which the most people were
accessing our assets, right,
just viewing them, getting
at them from Google results,
all sorts of ways, social media.
But there are a lot of developers
and other sorts of folks who want
to kind of get bulk access, right,
they want to drink from the firehose
of data and public domain materials.
So we took a crack at
revising some of the end points
in our digital collections API that
we first made available in 2013.
We were able to update the
documentation and our colleague,
Shawn Averkamp, was here yesterday
at the Hackathon working with folks
and making some recommendations
about how it could be used
and showing off some of the
newly revised documentation,
including a filter that
we were able to put
on that limits all the queries
to just public domain materials.
And the reason that's useful is
because in the API wherever possible
for the public domain
materials we have
in the captured responses direct
links to all the derivative types
that we have up to the
archival TIF that is the largest
and highest resolution version
that we have for these materials.
So that was great,
that was good work,
but then there was a third class
of folks that we started to think
about wanting to get access to the
data and maybe weren't really ready
or willing to out-of-the-gate
do some software development
and some coding to access the API.
And for those folks we put together
a release and put it on GitHub,
following the footsteps
of colleagues
in the Glam [Assumed
Spelling] community,
like MOMA [Assumed Spelling] and the
Cooper Hewitt [Assumed Spelling].
We took a snapshot of our
data, so this is a set
of records that's just our
public domain material.
And we put up item level records
and collection level records in CSV
and JSON formats for folks who maybe
are more comfortable in other tools,
like opening it up as a spreadsheet
and just sorting different
sections as columns.
And there was one other small
component of that GitHub release,
where we put a couple of
example scripts and utilities,
just to again sort of prime those
engines and give people examples
of the kind of things that they
can use to interrogate the data
that we made available
through GitHub.
So we put all that work in all
that release and made it available
on January 6th, but wouldn't
really have been possible
if we hadn't had some really clear
and unambiguous right statements,
right, some really clear signals
about which materials were available
for use and how they
were available for use.
Greg is going to tell you
all about how we did that.
>> Greg Cram: So my story at
NYPL begins with this date, 1923.
NYPL had been digitizing material
for 10 years before I arrived
at the Library, before my
position had even been created.
NYPL was digitizing bookplates from
books published primarily from 1923
because they thought that
was safe and comfortable.
And, as Maura [Assumed
Spelling] said this morning,
it's become apparent that having
a digital library that ends
in 1923 was not sufficient
for today.
We wanted to expand our
digitization efforts and break
through this 1923 barrier.
That means that we need to take
advantage of the exceptions
and limitations in copyright
law, but we also need
to understand the contours
of the public domain.
And that's where I come in, I was
hired just over five years ago
at NYPL and I help manage the
Institution's risk by gathering data
about our items, analyzing
it and recording it
to describe how we
can use each asset.
Expanding the scope of digitization
meant taking on some risk,
admittedly, of copyright
infringement
and that risk isn't
something to be taken lightly.
Statutory damages are up to
$150,000 per work infringed.
Digitizing 10 items and
hitting that elusive,
that magical number is $1.5
million in potential damages.
We don't digitize 10 items at a
time, we digitize in the thousands,
so digitizing a thousand items
and getting copyright
wrong would be $150 million
in the absolute worst case scenario.
So those numbers get really scary
really quickly when you're talking
to a Board of Library Directors.
So because these stakes were
so high the libraries needed
to do the research
necessary to understand
and accept these kinds of risks.
So after all that research was
done, it is done about these assets,
the question was how do we
make this research actionable?
So we began looking for
prebuilt rights databases
where we could input the
data and have a control
of downstream web properties.
Unfortunately, what
we found surprised us.
In an industry that cares a
lot about standardized metadata
and standardized schemas we found a
real significant lack of consistency
in rights metadata schemas.
For the most part rights metadata
today is found in some kind
of free text field, usually in
some kind of DC rights field,
and it's really not useful.
So without having a rights database
prebuilt for us we ended up having
to build our own, and it's part
of our metadata management system.
In the right side of the MMS
systems we record the provenance
of how we acquired an object,
do we get any donor restrictions
or any licenses that came
with that acquisition,
did we secure any licenses
that we can record subsequent
to the acquisition of that material.
We also want to record
the information
and research that's useful in
determining the copyright status
of these assets, and we also want
to note how the object can be used
so it can be programmatically
actionable
by NYPL's digital properties.
We do all of that by entering
data into the rights database,
which is part of this system.
So we didn't start out recording
copyright status determinations.
Five years ago we made
educated guesses
about what the copyright status
might be and what we can do
with those assets and reviewed
each object for those uses,
but after a few years it became
really clear really quickly
that we weren't going to be able to
predict every single use NYPL wants
to make of a digital asset.
So we needed to find another way
to classify these assets
in our repository.
So thanks to [inaudible] rights
database we could see the potential
applications for recording the
copyright status determinations
and making them
into a programmatically
actionable statements.
So about three years
ago we began evaluating
and recording copyright status
from nations in our database.
Unfortunately, determining copyright
status and determining what is
in a public domain isn't so tricky,
there isn't some magical database
in the copyright office across
the street that has a registry
of all things in the public domain.
So without that official
database of identified works
in the public domain we had
to do the same thing,
we had to build our own.
So we've had to make those
determinations ourselves.
Luckily, we've got some really good
tools, some really helpful tools
to make the law easier
to walk through,
but those tools are
really only as good
as the factual information
we have on hand.
Unfortunately, we're often
missing important information
to help us make a high
confidence determination
about the copyright status.
Take, for example, this letter from
1879 written by Samuel Clemens,
although this letter appears
to be in the public domain,
for some very quirky reasons
in copyright law it's actually
in copyright because
of the publication
of it during a certain magical time.
[laughter] So it's really difficult
just looking at an archival item
to determine whether that item
was subsequently published
or is in copyright today.
That's the problem we've struggled
with with archival material.
So I started five years ago and
my team's assignment has been
to review the last 10 years
of digitization at NYPL,
as well as keep up with the
going forward digitization.
So here's my team, at NYPL we've
got our team researching, analyzing
and entering the rights information.
There's me, there's a guy named
Kiowa Hammons, and that's it.
[laughter] So although we're
a really small team we've been
averaging about a thousand
captures a day at this point,
it's determining and adding
copyright status information
to those captures.
And by capture I mean a single
page in a book or a photograph,
but we're adding about a
thousand captures a day.
This is our burn down chart.
This is our internal tracking
of how fast we're moving
through our database.
Since May of 2014 we've added
copyright status determinations
to about 640,000 captures, and
of the database we have 17% left
to review and add statuses to.
We think we're going to get through
that in the next six months or so.
We're hoping that the rest of it
is going to be as straightforward
as the previous, and we'll see.
So of the 847,000 items
we've digitized we believe
at least 196,000 are
in the public domain.
And by public domain in
this case I mean no known US
copyright restrictions.
The New York Times described
that phrase as a wonky phrase,
and we agree, but there's a reason
why we had to say, we didn't want
to say public domain at this point.
And, in part, because we wanted to
be a little more accurate than that.
There's two problems with just
saying public domain and leaving it
at that without some
reference to something else.
First, there's no - first,
this public domain
determination is inherently limited
to the country's law that
you're applying it to.
There is no international copyright
law, instead we've got a patchwork
of individual country's laws.
So we had to limit this
down to US copyright
because that's the only
law that we evaluate under.
Second, we also wanted to be clear
that we've only evaluated copyright
issues, not other kinds of issues
like trademark or rights of
publicity, so we wanted to be clear
about that and that's why we used
the phrase no known copyright
restriction, no known US
copyright restrictions.
But today with the launch of
rightstatements.org we are going
to be switching over
our wonky phrase to one
of the three public domain
options that's out there today.
So with this foundation
of copyright information
and copyright status determinations
the Library felt really comfortable
about the risk issues in making
this high resolution release happen.
So after working with the
Director of the Library,
she ended up approving the high
resolution release of these images
and that's why we have 197,000 up.
And one other note about public
graphic metadata that's relevant
to copyright issues, copyright
doesn't protect factual information
and most of the bibliographic data
in our repository is just
that, it's just facts.
However, to the extent that
there is any kind of copyright
in the metadata we have
we've applied a CC0 waver,
we've waived our rights under
copyright to that information.
All right, so my team will
continue to review the digitization
and chip away at our backlog
and we'll keep knocking
down that number as
low as we can get.
I'll handle it over to Shana now.
>> Shana Kimball: All right,
so we've got our copyright
house in order.
We've enhanced our access
to our API and data.
We've turned brighter lights
on in digital collections
to the public domain items.
Next up is how do we go about like
revving these engines for reuse?
The first way we did this
was issuing a formal call
for what we're calling an
NYPL Labs Remix Residency.
This is including a stipend,
two people will be chosen
and it includes a stipend,
the opportunity to consult
with Library experts on
projects, the opportunity to work
in the Library at one of
our research study rooms,
and to showcase what's made
at NYPL through this program.
In issuing this call for sort of
remixing these public domain works
through this residency program
we're really building on a tradition
that the Library has had for,
and many research libraries have
of supporting scholars and
researchers in the creation
of new works through
offerings of special space
and consultation opportunities
and sometimes stipends
to do that kind of work.
And we know that at Labs
we want to sort of bring
that core mission forward
and apply it
to the creation and digital context.
We're also building on something
that we prototyped last year,
a Net Artist Residency that
we launched in collaboration
with Electric Objects, a
startup that creates screens
for the display of digital art.
We paired this with a prior
public domain release we had done
with our cardographic
works back in 2014,
and we positioned those
open access maps
as source material
for new creations.
Through a competitive review process
we chose Jennie O'Dell [Assumed
Spelling] as the winner
of this residency,
and she's a San Francisco
based artist who works
with Google satellite imagery
and creates really
amazing digital collages.
Here you're seeing a
collage that she created
out of shipping containers.
Here's one of cropped circles, and
so she kind of crops these and sort
of rearranges them and really
plays with perspective in scale
in really interesting ways.
For a residency with her
and Electric Objects she took an
interest in the decorative elements
on the borders of 17th and
18th Century Dutch maps
and created this series of collages
that kind of applied her methodology
but to these historical works.
To round all this out we had an
artist talk at the Map Division
in NYPL, and this work is on
display still in our Map Division.
So again this is really
what we are trying to drive
at with our Remix Residency
and really opening this
up to the fuller sort of
public domain release overall.
To round all of this out and to
kind of continue to drive attention
to that residency, that call
for proposals for the residency,
and also to kind of
continue to communicate
about the public domain release
for the months or for the weeks
and months after the January
drop date, we wanted to also sort
of have our staff be blogging
about particular collections
and also position those collections
for different kinds of users,
so educators or creatives,
things like that.
So that was good, that should have
been enough, and December 2015
like that's where we were.
At the same time, though,
our developers and our R
and D team were busy kind of working
on some elective hack projects,
some really cool demonstrations
of kind of like using the data
and coming up with some new projects
that really demonstrated sort
of both what people could apply
to do with the Remix Residency,
but also just to really provide some
like new ways to kind of explore
and experience these
really rich assets
that we had in this collection.
So Josh is going to take you through
how we really like put the pedal
to the ground in revving these
engines for reuse and sort of talk
about these hot projects.
>> Josh Hadro: Okay, these are fun.
The developers had a
lot of fun doing these.
As Shana said, these
were kind of born
out of personal interest, right?
So they sort of found the segments
of the public domain release
that were of interest
to them or spoke to them
and then built some projects on
top of these, and that's part
of why we kind of held the
release to be able to include these
with that to show kind of the
passion projects and what can come
out of the public domain collection
materials that we were offering.
So there's three of these projects
I'll talk through and then kind
of a fourth overarching one
that was more of a visualization
of the entire body of stuff.
This first one, Mansion Maniac,
takes as its source
materials a neat publication
from the early 20th Century that
was these beautiful floor plans
of these massive New York City
apartments, right, these like grand,
elegant named buildings and showed
all the different rooms, right,
the parlors and the maids
quarters and the libraries and all
of the entrances and each room and
the square footage and all of that.
And the developer kind of cut these
apart and then created an interface.
I'll show you the interaction in
just a second that allowed you
to traverse from one room to another
with a little sprite character
and see how many different rooms you
could chain together as they're sort
of randomly composed by connecting
the portals to the different rooms.
So you start always at the entrance
to one of these grand buildings.
[pause] And so you sort of wander
around, right, some of the hallways,
sometimes it's a kitchen, sometimes
you chain together a couple
of different hallways.
I can't exactly see where
the sprite is in the process,
but some of these you can,
you end up chaining together
and there's almost a game-like
element where people have competed
to see like how large an
apartment you can create,
especially since most of us live
in shoebox style apartments this is
kind of like a fun little way of,
you know, fantasy lands,
apartment building project.
So that's Mansion Maniac.
Another one that takes a similar era
of source material is
Street View Then and Now
in New York City's Fifth Avenue.
And so there's a publication
from 1911 that took,
that published wide-angle images
of every block of Fifth Avenue
from Washington Square Park to
what became our Discovery Park
up in Harlem, so images
of every block
and then essentially just
juxtaposes the 1911 view
with a Google street view
and adds a few engagement
or interaction opportunities to
navigate from one side of the Island
to another and switch around sides
of the street and you can kind
of view many of the buildings
that are still there,
many of them that have
been remodeled or torn
down as the skyline has
changed and all aspects
of Fifth Avenue have kind of updated
over those 104 years, is that right?
Yes, 104 years.
So two kind of more playful
interventions, but there was a third
that actually took the
historical materials
in our public domain release and
injected it into the conversation
about ongoing racial
inequality in the country.
This one takes as its
source material a set
of publications called The Green
Books, which were published
from 1936 to 1967 and were each
year listings of places like hotels
and restaurants that were
welcoming to black travelers
as they traveled the
country in an era
of Jim Crow laws and Sundown towns.
And so there are - there's
an element here where each
of the listings we were able to
extract, to do some OCR processing
and extract those things and place
them on a map so there's kind
of a cluster view, but there's
also a tool I'll show you
in just a second that
allows you to kind
of apply modern mapping
technology, right,
sort of Google Map style path
creation using just the listings
from these volumes.
And so as you take a look
at the - hopefully working -
interaction here, we were
able to get two volumes done,
so we have data from
1947 and data from 1956.
There's actually another
kind of neat example
of cultural heritage cross
promotion, the 1947 volume - or, no,
sorry - the 1956 volume is actually
data extracted from that volume
from the University of South
Carolina, so we were able
to use their data from that volume
merged with our data from 1947.
And this has proven to be like
a really popular tool just
to see the listings, as well as
we've heard about uses in classrooms
and all sorts of things like that.
The final piece, the final projects,
I guess, was meant to answer kind
of a sub-question about
this 187,000 items,
the question of how do you help
people even look at 187,000 items?
So this was a visualization
experiment in giving access to those
and it creates a sprite, a little
tiny thumbnail for each one
of the 187,000 items and gives a
couple of different browse paths
to sort them and then click
through from each image thumbnail
to the item page on the
digital collections platform.
And so you can see here there are
four different ways of sorting them.
You can sort by date
created, pulling metadata
from the underlying
objects, there's also a way
to sort using the genre terms from
the metadata, but the final example
up on the screen is
kind of a neat one
that used the average
color value of the image.
I was able to sort those,
so what you don't see
in that example is the fact
that something like 60%
of the collections are yellow or
brown, right, it's the problem
of the 19th Century,
everything is the same color.
And so this is kind of the set
of material that we were able
to put together and wait till
January to release all together,
to really give those kind of
shining examples of what we did
with the materials and
hopefully set kind of the bar
for what we are hoping
other people will do
with the exact same
body of materials.
>> Shana Kimball: Okay, so
how did the public respond?
I'm going to start with sort of
an overview of press responses.
First up was a really amazing
feature in the New York Times
that really kind of went through
every sort of aspect of our release.
It really even started
out with Mansion Maniac,
which kind of really validated
like our strategic choice to kind
of package all of this up together.
Got a shout out to Dan Cohen
for giving us an amazing quote,
thank you for blurbing our
public domain release, Dan.
And then from there like the news
was just really kind of a flood,
like we had like over 100 news
outlets that really picked
up the story, everything
from national news outlets,
like Washington Post, The
Atlantic, PBS News Hour, local news.
In the US all kinds of
outlets, like really sort
of finding their own
sort of collections,
like things that represented
their locality in our collection.
The same thing with international
news outlets, Japan, Russia,
Singapore, India and many more,
so finding that sort of story
and that representation in
our digital collections.
And some of them were
really putting history
in the context of the present.
This is one of my favorite examples.
What would Beyonce's formation might
have looked like if it were set
in the 1930s, so kind of pulling
in some photographs from the FSA
to kind of like illustrate
what a historical version
of that video would be.
More seriously, PRI's the world
took 19th Century photographs
of Ellis Island that were - of
Ellis Island immigrants that are
in our digital collections and
juxtaposed those with those
of contemporary Syrian refugees
to really sort of draw some sort
of commonalities between
these across time,
and that was really amazing to see.
Also the public kind of
went nuts on the internet,
people are comparing our digital
or our public domain release
with the biggest drop in Beyonce,
and this is the first time
and only time I've referenced
Beyonce twice in a presentation.
So thank you for giving
me this chance.
I also got some great
kudos from Cory Doctorow,
a great open access advocate who
gave us a nice pat on the back.
And then like it turned out
that we had sort of developed
like everyone's favorite
procrastination machine,
so people are getting like
lost in the collections,
they're getting addicted
to exploring and browsing,
I think our visualization
tool was a big engine of this.
Land ladies in rural
Vermont are sort of trying
to bribe Jessamyn West, one
of our librarian colleagues,
with fudge to help her
find public domain items.
As Josh mentioned, people were
really enjoying sort of sharing
out their generated sort of
mansions, using Mansion Maniac.
MEMs [Assumed Spelling] start
getting feeded, I'd like to add you
to my professional
network on LinkedIn.
Gift making, actually one of our
gift makers is in the audience -
Derek [Assumed Spelling], thank you,
you made this one I'm
showing right now, yes?
>> Yes.
>> Shana Kimball: And then also
we issued a call or just asked you
to hashtag really for
any sort of examples
of organic reuse that
were coming about.
We've seen hundreds of uses of this
hashtag and remix on both Instagram
and Tumblr, I would encourage
you to explore those,
including one of our favorite
examples of some guy in Williamsburg
who has been remixing public
domain images and using them
on skateboard decks
and like selling those,
which has been really
kind of fun to see.
So like check those out.
Illustrators, designers
drawing a lot of inspiration
for their own creative
works from the collections.
A couple weeks after the release
we participated in a Glam wide sort
of promotional effort called
Color Our Collections.
We created a little coloring booklet
out of a select 12 or so images.
Made those available for
download and participated in this
like sort of, like I
said, this broader sort
of celebration of open materials.
And DeUser [Assumed Spelling] just
created her own coloring book,
as well, out of Bernice
Abbott's photos.
Seeing some examples of reuse
in the digital humanities
community, as well.
I want to thank John Ressig [Assumed
Spelling] for teaching me how
to say paste-C [Assumed
Spelling], this sort of tool
that Ryan Baumann is using to kind
of do an image recognition analysis
across our open collections
and those
of the Rijks [Assumed
Spelling] Museum.
And also Miriam Posner, a Digital
Humanities Professor, really excited
about using these in her class.
Our API has been used to
create some Twitter Bots,
including one by Shawn Averkamp,
our colleague in the audience here
today, I Classify Bot is hers.
And, finally, another
sort of category
of response has been the response
to the call for proposals,
so we received close to 300
applications by computer scientists,
artists, hacktivist collectives,
educators, filmmakers,
data visualization
designers, uralists,
a well-known Indy rock musician,
a designer of a classic
video arcade game.
We're in the selection process
right now, but we're so sort
of thrilled by this response.
People are proposing new works
as diverse as like transmedia,
narratives starring an army of Bots,
immersive visual reality
experiences, scavenger hunts,
animations, and the list goes on.
We're going to be really
excited to be sharing the results
of that work in the coming months.
And to tell you, no
presentation would be complete
without some numbers, so
I'm going to turn this
over to Josh to give you a rundown.
>> Josh Hadro: Okay,
you wanted big numbers,
you're going to get big numbers.
So this is my favorite,
sort of an anecdotal piece,
but in the first five weeks of the
launch, right, January 6th just
into February, we had more traffic,
more visits to our digital
collections platform than we had
in the entire calendar year of 2015.
And previous to the launch we had
thought that the calendar year
of 2015 was going pretty well.
So that was really edifying.
Three months out, so
January 6th to April 6th,
we had 1.8 million
sessions to the site,
but we also had 3.2
million calls for API,
right, trying to pull the data.
So it kind of confirmed our
suspicion that both aspects
of this were desirable
and being used.
We had 680,000 some
downloads of assets
from our digital collections
platform and 290,000 of those were
of these kind of previously
uncovered high resolution assets
that we were making available.
Beyond that, right, so we're
now 14 weeks out from the day
of the drop and we had a huge spike.
Then, right, as these things
go the traffic comes back down,
and it has come back down but it
hasn't come all the way back down.
Every day, we haven't had
a day that has been less
than one-and-a-half times
the previous traffic.
So we're feeling like that
we're settling into a baseline
of one-and-a-half to two
times increase in traffic.
There's been an ongoing 50%
increase in pages view3ed,
25% increase in the
length of the session.
So people, it sort of stuck, right?
That's the takeaway,
separate from the numbers,
is that this wasn't sort
of a blip on the radar,
this had a lasting impression
in terms of the way it's lodged
into search results and
traffic to our site.
>> Shana Kimball: I'm going to bring
this on home with some takeaways
and then leave some
time for questions.
So I guess for us, obviously,
there's a huge demand
for this stuff.
And like we knew it
was going to be big,
but like people really,
really love this.
We thought we were in the giving
away free content business,
but it turns out that we're really
in like an audience
development business,
that we really developed a huge
sort of, yes, audience and people
who are not just like looking at
the stuff but really want to use it.
What's going to be a challenge for
us ahead is sustaining this demand
and interest and kind of
continuing a sort of steady drumbeat
of promotion and for like
things that we digitize,
things that Greg's team, his
huge team, is sort of clearing.
We're going to be soon approaching
200,000 public domain images,
so like these are new opportunities
for us to kind of like continue
to share out about the
public domain collections
and position them for reuse.
And I also think a big takeaway
for us has also been to think
in a new way about our R
and D capacity as a lab.
These were like lightweight
rapid proofs of concepts
that demonstrate what can be done
with open collections and data,
and we just really feel
like that they were
such a critical part of
this release overall.
And so that's something that we're
going to be really thinking about
and sort of applying I think in
the future for other projects.
And, finally, because we are at
DPLA Fest if we achieved what we did
with NYPL collections, like sort
of imagine like what happens
when we were all like
revving our engines for reuse
and it's a collective like
at the community as DPLA.
So thank you.
We have some time for questions.
You guys want to come up?
[ Pause ]
Oh, okay. No, Dan deferred to you,
so we'll go Derek, then Dan, yes.
Sorry, misread the language.
[laughter]
[ Inaudible ]
>> Greg Cram: So everything
- identifying things
in the public domain was
tricky and that was hard
and because the copyright
office doesn't keep a record
of that it was even harder.
I think doing things like this,
demonstrating that we can identify
things in the public domain
and hopefully all of us using
rightstatements, dot org statements,
we're going to develop
almost by accident
but probably not a public domain
registry of cultural heritage items.
And I think that there's
some power in that,
demonstrating what we think
is in the public domain.
because what we expect is
going to happen is that things
in NYPL's collections that we mark
as public domain are going to be
in your collections and you might
be able to rely or want to rely
on our determination so you can
kind of move past that item.
In the context of a larger copyright
policy we are heavily engaged
in those conversations in DC.
I'm down here a lot, talk to
Congress and to the copyright office
about better copyright
policy and not messing
up what we've got right now.
I think that demonstrating the
value of public domain is good
when we start talking
about whether we're going
to extend copyright
protection for another 20 years,
if that proposal ever goes anywhere.
I think things like this, showing
the value of public domain,
will eliminate or hopefully
reduce that argument.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Greg Cram: Okay, so the first
step is start to identify the things
that are in the public
domain, and then ...
>> Shana Kimball: Yes, I
mean I guess, you know,
I think that thinking about
collection strengths and thinking
about audiences that
might be interested
and not the usual suspects.
And I think that there's like so
many different forms of that kind
of activation of this
kind of content can take.
Hosting hackathons, you know,
inviting artist commissions.
It doesn't have to be
something that's a competition,
it can be something
that's a collaboration.
I think by creating
an experience around,
like thinking about like what are
sort of like interesting experiences
that you can create
around these collections.
And, like I said, so they
could take, yes, several forms.
I also want to shout out to F.E.
Kobsolus [Assumed Spelling],
who is here from the
Smithsonian Archives,
who has just created this
amazing case study institutions
across the Glam sector who have
opened their materials and has
like done a really amazing job
of sort of like gathering sort
of anecdotal and other kinds of data
that are sort of showing the impact.
And so that other institutions
who are thinking about trying
to do something like this will have
that as like a really great tool.
F.E. if you could like
tweet that out, yes, great.
So, yes, I would say
like read F.E.'s report,
get your copyright house
in order, and like think
about unique opportunities to
activate those collections.
Did you want to add anything, Josh?
>> Josh Hadro: Like creating
context around it, right,
like it's one thing to do - you
know, we chose to do this kind
of all-in heterogeneous
drop of 187,000 things,
but we had considered doing
more of a serialized approach
and doing batches and
collections, right?
We did, actually, the first one
we did was 20,000 maps in 2014
and that actually was really
powerful in its own way
because it was able to be targeted
and we were able to create context
around it in its own way.
So I think that could
be another strategy.
If it isn't necessarily the right
way to do it, everything all
at once, you can maybe
serialize it and do - you know,
to do smaller amount of
materials with the right context,
that will help it sing, that will
help it reach the activation energy
to probably extend it even further.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Greg Cram: Give it to me, so
for now I don't think we're going
to be enabling high res
downloads of undetermined,
things that are undetermined.
I think that for us although
we like to push the envelope
in some ways we are still
a little more conservative.
We don't have sovereign immunity.
We are a private corporation
and we report to a Board.
So there's - I think there's a
little bit of a concern there
with some of that material.
I think, though, that we can
- we're exposing more items
that would have otherwise
been kept in the dark
by doing this rights review work.
things that are, you know,
even things published as late
as 1989 we've been able
to make available online
because we've been using
the copyright laws,
we've identified them as
public domain, or even orphans
where we think that the work
is an orphan work and we think
that there's no potential
for a lawsuit,
I think we've been making those
things available more broadly.
So maybe not in a high res, but in
a way that exposes that collection
in a way that we wouldn't
have done that 10 years ago
or even probably five years ago.
We've felt more and more
confident with their use.
>> Josh Hadro: Just
to answer another part
of your question, what next?
Another part of what's next is
applying the right statements
and I think we'll do that
basically as soon as we can.
And beyond that I think we're
not racing to double the number,
2017 we need to now
have 400,000 statements.
I think for us adding more -
that is not necessarily the
best thing to do for us.
I think it's more about continuing
what we have been able to do,
highlighting gems that have
been digitized for 10 years.
there's a new project that we
didn't build called [inaudible]
which used not necessarily
public domain photos but photos
from our collection, but they'd
been online for 10 or 11 years
but it was this mapping [inaudible]
that really allowed them to sing.
And so helping I think identify
those areas and helping developers,
whatever, get access to those.
So it's about activating maybe
the stuff that we already did,
instead of doing a whole new
release, just refreshing that one.
>> Shana Kimball: Yes, and I'll
say, too, just like from the reuse,
sort of like the program
aspect of this,
like the sort of public outreach
aspect, this idea of reuse is just
so interesting to our
like our Library overall,
like both on the digital
side of things but also
in the Research Library
more broadly.
So we're really interested
in sort of starting to think
about how do we continue
to sort of tell the stories
of how our collections are being
used, the kind of interesting things
that are being created out of
them, eBay, an academic book,
work of journalism or some kind
of interesting like math interface
to a historic collection.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Josh Hadro: So the development
of The Green Book project,
I mean this is - we love telling
the story because this is kind
of a perfect series of events.
So it was proposed for digitization
more than a year-and-a-half ago,
I mean almost two years ago
at this point by a curator
of the Schomburg Center who knew
the history of the materials.
We had basically a complete run, I
think we're only missing one volume.
And said we have to digitize these,
they're kind of some amazing
artifacts that we have.
So we digitized them
and we put them online.
Again, they were online
for a year-and-a-half,
and a few people say them and maybe
to them it wasn't the
right format for use.
And so we had been talking
to the curator and sort
of just said a back
burner idea for us.
And then in the run-up to the
public domain release the developer
who built that kind of said,
okay, this is what I want
to spend a couple of weeks
doing, and then actually worked
with a bunch of folks to
do the text processing
and extracting all
the different things.
So that was a great example
of an idea that had been sort
of waiting to activate [inaudible].
And in terms of sort of
long-term sustainability,
like these were basically meant
to be quick projects released
as examples and they're [inaudible].
It's not like there are servers
that are running or a lot
of infrastructure that's
involved in keeping these,
but we publish all the code
openly for all of those, too,
so that's not a sustainability
strategy but it is like meant to be
as an example that hopefully other
people can take and use [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
>> Josh Hadro: To answer the second
one first, I don't talk to donors
and there's a whole
separate staff that does,
but we know anecdotally it
absolutely has, just the response
to this has informed
conversations that have been had
about trying to acquire collections.
And so that, positively in basically
every case that we've heard.
And in terms of how
it's informed digitized.
The conversation about what
to select is sort of
changing every week.
It's like we had already been
talking about the privacy
of public domain and
how that really aligns
with our mission before we
did the public domain release.
So I think that was
already pretty well baked
into what is usually
selected for digitization,
but it is absolutely informing
and especially as we get more data
and more anecdotal use about
what has really surprised us
in terms of use and reuse.
It has, but it's hard to
tell you exactly how it has.
We have so many different
streams we're feeding
into what is desired
to go into the cameras.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Shana Kimball: I mean Josh
and I both have like shady pasts
in publishing and so does our
Director [inaudible] and like, yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Shana Kimball: It must have.
[laughter]
>> Josh Hadro: An editorial,
I mean, yes.
I don't know that we like
mapped it out into the sort
of publication schedule
or exactly, right.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Shana Kimball: I mean I guess
like part of my role is kind
of helping the NYPL's like
flagship social media channels,
kind of like activate
what we're doing in Labs.
So it's like we're running
our own social media.
We have this whole sort of program
design, but a big part of what we
like jokingly call it, like the
institutional hacking - you know,
so it's like how do we make sure?
Because we don't like think
of Facebook, I mean it's just
like another communication
channel, Tumblr, Instagram, Twitter,
and our channels have so many -
like those flagship accounts have
so many followers and so that was
a really critical part of helping
to kind of like get the word
out and sustain interest.
And even Labs, like I think our
account is like 10,000 followers,
like that's good but it's
not like web scale, you know?
And the NYPL accounts - I mean
if I'm answering your question
appropriately, like, no,
we don't see that that is
like a bad way for people
to be encountering these images
or sharing them or, if anything,
it's like this very visible daily
reminder that, yes, people are just
like enjoying just the sharing.
Like this is an amazing collection.
There's this radio producer,
I think it's Science Friday,
who just has become obsessed with
our - it's like every day he does
like some sort of like
tweet storm of his favorites
or science related tweets and
like he's a fan, you know?
And he's helping to kind of
share with his audiences,
and we see that as a
really great outcome.
All right, thanks.
[applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.